مر 100 يوم 100 مره اشرقت الشمس وغابت راح
خريف وجاء شتاء مسحت وجوه وعائلات وحواضر
وغزه وحيده تواجه الطائرات والقنابل
والخذلان والظلم المريب ذاك الذي ينسى
القاتل ويسائل الضحيه مثل حكايه تروى من
الخاتمه كان رتيبا مثل سابقه اليوم ما قبل
المئه في غزه يوم من سنه تطوي سنه خلف
السياج هناك حيث الاحتلال ممسك بمفاصل
الحياه يحسب عليهم الماء والهواء وما
ياكلون ويشربون يحشر مليونين ونصف مليون
انسان في مساحه مدينه عاديه في الكون
الوسيع ثم يجثم على انفاسها ويشن عليها
حربا مدمره كل عامين او ثلاث حتى بغته في
يوم لن ينساه وكان الاسم تصريح حاله طوفان
الاقصى ولما يكون للاقصى طوفان لولا انه
ماسور يستغيث من تدنيس وانتهاك وتهويد ومن
ورائه الضفه والقدس تقدمهما المستوطنات
كانت فلسطين تبتعد تكاد تصبح نسيا في
اهتمامات العالم المتجاهل وعبء يعيق ما
يعرف بالتطبيع الشامل بعدما ارتات واشنطن
ان القفز فوق العقده من حلها والعقده قضيه
فلسطين التي دخلت كما يقول كثير من اهلها
طور التصفيه والتصفيه انهاء غير صاخب
بالضروره يمكن ان يحدث بالصمت والنسيان
فلتم المشاريع التجاريه القاريه ويتحقق
التلاقي فوق اوصال ما بقي من فلسطين اما
حقوق اهلها فالزمان كفيل باندثار لكن
المقاومه في السابع من اكتوبر
قررت امرا
اخر هز طوفان اسرائيل حين ضربها في مكمن
قوتها وهي الردع وبعد 100 يوم لم تبقى
جريمه ضد القانون الدولي لم يرتكبها
الاحتلال مدفوعا بالثار والخوف ويواصل
لليوم حربا عنوانها المجازر لم توصله لاي
من اهدافه اما اهل غزه فيدعون ثمنا باهظا
كان ليكون اقل او لا يكون لولا الموقف
العربي الذي وصف
بالصادمة
مر 100 يوم وغزه تتالم وتقاوم في حرب
سيكون من شان صمودها فيها وفق كثر تغيير
وجه المنطقه ليصبح حلم التحرر حقيقه لا
تسويقا سياسيا يشتري الوقت ولا يتجاوز
براي منتقديه عبارات بليده عن سلام لا
يراه احد ثمت طريق اخر قالت غزه
وفعلت